anémone je te ferai pas l'affront de
leur parler des césars pasquale tant par
les 168 fois depuis l'an passé par
monaco après qu'un pas ouais ouais franc
parler d'autre chose alors oui ton
copain césar christian roth est illégal
michela les a rencontrés après un grand
flic une dépression non mais j'ai
commencé il ya dix ans les rencontres et
quand on a fait une descente semble
avignon et puis je les ai revus un
moment où effectivement j'étais mal et
tout et j'aurais dis moi ça a l'air bien
ce qu'ont fait divers vous amuser plus
ou mois et
et alors pourquoi voudriez pas que je
joue avec nous et il me dit ah bon je
sens une vedette s'est tous dit oui je
m'embête d'accord avec vous ouais ouais
et bien jouer dans notre cour course et
c'est l'atelier comment écouter ça
commence le temps de mise en scène s'est
passée votre première et la troisième
tranche à quoi un baby boom
non c'est terrible ça parle de 10,1 pas
le départ de saint régis transféré mais
là c'est moins terrible que ça peut être
parce que si vous
il est clair qu'elle espérait jusque là
parce qu'elle sait diplomatique a
décroché pour exister mais bon c'est
l'histoire est alors en fait pas du tout
une description de ces séductrices aux
enfants noté cacher tout le temps de
trancher leur mec est tout et qui finit
par adopter des petits fous voilà donc
là pour aller jusqu'au bout de la
relation du couple était enfant comment
ils vont encore ouais super de bonne
chaire ensuite rentré juste une petite
les soeurs hilton dans ce massif andin
j'ai pas eu le temps d'aller au fond des
cales en bois
voilà je l'envié de faire un
questionnaire d'enfer spécial pour toi
je te jure
[Musique]
comment je vais te donner un exemple je
mettrai à lahti pour savoir que je peux
battre et la magie noire
je sais que tu vas voir c'est très
gentil et première question mais
vraiment la question qu'ont type est ce
que tu préfères trompé ajoute amer mais
j'aime les goûts voilà déjà trouvé la
question qu'ont par définition c'est
celle à laquelle on ne peut pas répondre
sur moi j'ai dit je répondu ouais
deuxième question c'est là tu verras que
tu pourras pas dire les deux est-ce que
tu préfère vivre disant très très très
très riche vraiment avec tout ce que tu
veux j'ai des 747 on est enceinte
voilà alors son temps pour moi sentant
pas d'accord avec moi
curieuse pas que je suis pas juriste est
sûr qu reebok alors troisième question
qu'on est ce que tu serais prête à
mourir là maintenant ça tu meurs
juste après la première tumeur pour que
un million de petits éthiopien puisse
survivre à ces quand même s'adresse à
régler les questions en gros ça pourrait
s'appeler les questions qu elle est
ainsi la mise en place qu'est ce que
l'on me demandera l'aide du courage il
dort une heure
le comique populaire que c'est une
réponse des petits enfants ses deux
petits-enfants
déjà club imagine tu as plus de pognon
t'as plus rien leur donner à manger sont
vraiment je vais les faire tant à
travers non si c'est le pire que ça
l'image et des crampes à gimont ces
pauvres enfants pour les dissimuler
est ce que tu es vendre de la drogue à
la sortie des écoles oui pour tes
enfants puissent survivre parce que tu
le ferais ça c'est la question qu'ont
par excellence
non je préfère les vendre comme s'il
survivra quand on comprend des ventes à
parler politique pour qui a qui trouvent
tue le plus de circonstances atténuantes
staline hitler ou polpot voit laurent
coste à lille et hitler foot je préfère
quand même pas très bien passé entre les
pierres hyper mal de tête du mec c'est
quand même angolais habituel disons que
ces trois dictateurs de qu'elle tue
excuses le plus d'épreuves staline
hitler ou paul paul et moi je vous dis
mais qui sont à mon goût lien problème
tu leur parles bien c'était bien pour
toi les manteaux pouvoir quand tu penses
que c'est des psychopathes et qu'ils ont
des circonstances atténuantes pouvoir je
me dis que les gens quand même pouvoir
déjà compter sur moi j'aurais dit
politique parce qu'ils se sentent le
reste sachez ce parti écrit en gras bon
alors je continue
quelle race préfères-tu les jaunes les
blancs les noirs ou les rouges qu'est-ce
que tu préfèrerais être sourde muette
aveugle première solution
ou alors avoir les quatre membres coupés
à ras la prévenue est aveugle première
solution de 0,4 mon combat c'est que tu
peux quand même regarder la télé tu peux
regarder sabatier ça qui écoute je ne
sais pas là tu vois je deviens
j'aimerais entendre comme on verra
maintenant tu es seul seul dans un
refuge de montagne perdu à huit jours de
marche de 2 du premier être vivant
1 et puis tu as envie de faire l'amour
parce que ça fait un mois que tu es dans
ce refuge
c est alors imagine bien à ce moment-là
qu'est ce que tu peux faire avec faire
l'amour avec les femmes pas qu'une
personne du même sexe que toi tu
t'habilles ça m'a pris c'est amusant
voilà ou alors se masturber oui c'est
comment s'avère assez consternante
personnes au japon du but avec à écouter
non non non non non alors maintenant si
tu devais vraiment toujours pas été dans
le refuge c'est avec un très bon ami
cette fois et y meurent de froid est-ce
que tu commences là et tout raid raid
est ce que tu veux qu'on serait par
contre pas manger le doigt ou les joues
[Musique]
charia rien à bouffer tout et rien avoué
l'attachement par deux jambes assez
commence par le jambon à toi moi je
commencerai par la juge par les jours
c'est déjà fini simone mazer pour coter
dans la pièce où tiger woods a fait part
par rapport à son mari ah oui d'accord
je suis son mari cher monsieur
oui je peux vous dire que c'est pas
facile
[Musique]
tu dois partir trois ans dans un
vaisseau spatial
qu'est-ce que tu choisis muriel robin
catherine lara ou marie paule belle six
jeunes hommes qui se rencontrent à ce
moment que tout autre chose et si tu
avais pas le choix tu préférais faire
l'amour avec un mec très laid ou une
fille très belle un mec très laid pas ce
que vont dire yonne il y en a qui ont
des talents cachés un nom parce qu'avec
une fille faut du matériel s'est tout de
suite ça entraîne des frais à qui trouve
tu le plus de circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui tapent des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles de
circonstances atténuantes
oui j'aime bien qu'ils se tapent des
petits moins on est sûr qu'elle les a
pas forcé au maire mes bijoux une amie
débarque chez toi à l'improviste qu'est
ce qui te gêne le plus qu'elle trouve
sur la table de nuit mangan fin
godemichet à toute façon c'est pas le
même usage
mais j'ai lu avec intérêt certain
discours de hitler et effectivement
c'est assez impressionnant mais non je
vous dirai peut m'arriver de lire ce
genre de truc c'est instructif
le mot le plus con en amour merci encore
oui oui le mou le bio à je vous en
raconter une à ce propos c'est un
camarade à moi qui étais un peu fauchés
et ebay sa dulcinée à soir de noël et
aux grands moments que tu verras et lady
joyeux noël
quand on a patiné c'est une solution si
c'était possible
est-ce que tu accepterais de d'échanger
une paralysie générale contre la faim
des inondations en bangladesh
bon
c'est à dire oui la charité chrétienne
mais me commanderait de choisir le
bangladesh mais je ne souhaite pas
répondre là si tu avais un perroquet tu
lui apprendrait ta ferme et le gaz tu as
pensé la capote ou alors coco arrête là
coco
après c'est la capote le perroquet faut
que ça vachement petite pour réussir à
ton avis faut être [ __ ] calculatrice
ou tueuse ça me déprime ça ils sont un
peu de naïveté là c'est mon dernier
reste
et oui public mais y'a personne
ah bon non et puis to be queen ou 150
chasseurs devant la porte
tu vois dans quelle situation tu nous
mets que les histoires de tourterelles
qui pourra les faire ça chez bourin du
bourget dire il est quoi 150 chasseurs
devant la porte le public a pas tous
rentrés ont dévalé 12h15 des pc cette
heure-ci ring pour toi personne c'est en
tous les cas tu vas pas être réoccupée
voilà de quoi doucher soeur d'accord ça
va voir ça ouais alors tous les soirs
puis le 4 juin
je joue une pièce de botho strauss au
théâtre de l'atelier qui s'appelle
personne d'autre la première fois qu'ils
ont entendu parler de botho strauss
jeudi qui a oui parce que c'était à
trois ans c'était avant qu'il soit monté
radio et je te dire que les auteurs
contemporains allemand tu vois bon et on
t'a répondu que c'était la coqueluche
des intellos du théâtre subventionné
mais alors tu penses toujours la même
chose
non mais c'est vrai que c'est un auteur
qui a été beaucoup monté ces dernières
années près et metteur en scène de
subventionner way et c'est un bon auteur
d'ailleurs ils ont raison de le monter
c'est quoi cette placer alors cette
pièce c'est une femme abandonnée qui
réalise c'est une femme de ma génération
mais qui à qui elle s'est mariée
classiquement
à 18 ans sans doute enfin s'est pas
marié d'ailleurs mais j'étais à la haye
la rencontre un type alors il faisait
semblant de faire les barricades m
d'être comme ça révolutionnaire et puis
en réalité bon elle l a complètement
malgré les apparences finalement elle a
endossé au fond le rôle traditionnel de
la femme se dévoile sommes probablement
elle a travaillé pour lui payer ses
études etc etc
et puis au bout de 17 ans le type sans
doute la baiser plus où je dis pas elle
a eu le malheur d'aller voir ailleurs et
là dessus on en a profité pour lui dire
à ben écoute regarde à peine que tu fais
donc moins cher mais je m'excuse je suis
obligée de partir maintenant bon avec
une petite fectivement je me mariais que
la petite est là elle prend tout sur la
gueule
il veut plus la voir genre en plus tu
vas pas faire des scènes ça traumatise
ma femme ma nouvelle femme bon et elle
se dit mais c'est vrai avoue 17 ans je
vais tout donner j'ai même pas d'enfant
j'ai rien rien rien
j'ai quarante balais et j'ai pas de
boulot enfin voilà et c'est sahel elle
se cogne la tête contre les murs elle
s'est pas seule elle passe par tous les
états de la gamme tous les états
possibles pendant une heure cinq tu vas
mental s'accrocher au théâtre quand même
un regret si les matelas plutôt la dent
dure non j'ai lu un truc utilisé sur
basique et mystique
c'était terrible non me disais que si
c'était non parce que tu comprends on
nous vante truc au nord est de la
violence du sexe c'est tout mais enfin
arrêtons moi je dire si on parle de sexe
bon l'an pire d'essence oui là on effet
j'apprends des trucs que j'irais pas
faire chez moi tu vois même le dernier
tango je faisais une espèce de violences
sexuelles de choses bon mais là
franchement on te dit que c'était un
film art chicon avec deux pipes un brutt
minou et c'est tout si c'est pour faire
ça tu le fais chez toi tu économises 60
balles bah ouais c'est vrai je peux le
faire moi-même s'agit
rob puis tu sais comment dire le
j'imagine c'est en prison ou que sais tu
as du mal en tant qu'algérien à trouver
une fille gentille joue tout d'abord
effectivement je comprends que ça peut
découler un petit peu mais quand tu as
la chance d'être tant qu au fond et
c'est très bête c'est très très très
très très bête tu vois et moi il ya un
degré de conneries ou au delà duquel je
m'ennuie profondément
et puis t'as pas de télé non plus chez
toi parce qu'il paraît que depuis que tu
as été cambriolée tap a racheté la télé
non parce que ça les scotch ale mon
espèce de ce pirate leur avis ils sont
comme ça et puis vannes si on pouvait
leur [ __ ] des pailles avec si on peut
leur faire rentrer du sucré comme ça
direct tu vas et ben alors du coup quand
ils ont pu la télé pendant quelques
jours ils sont un peu désorienté se
raccrochent oui non ils sont en manque
d'abord il ya ce vrai tu vois alors il
semble manquer crise et puis après ça
une bise oublions parles tu viens sage
en plus tu as dit grandir c'est
apprendre à renoncer c'est bien la
quarantaine si j'avais bu ouais on
étudie on ne peut pas avoir le soleil et
l'agrandir s'apprête à renoncer à ce
beau et d'admirer des moments je fait
assez admirable tout apprécié la
quarantaine quand même oui tu dis ma
lancée
quand on a 40 ans et ce qu'il faut faire
on connaît la valeur du temps tout ça ce
n'est pas d'avoir dit ça mitsubishi
relativement profonde quand tu étais
parti tu as dit paris ça pue ça pue ça
fait toujours à ça plus que j'aime
ouais ouais j'ai du mal non bah oui moi
je me suis habitué tous et enfin moi ah
bon toujours pas la quarantaine j'ai
passé l'âge d'être coquette c'est pas
vrai d'ailleurs c'est à dire on en dit
en souvenir puis à des trucs qui vous
échappe
je suis co kg poule avec ton petit
tailleur blanc la wii la wii ben oui tu
vois plus la non juppé en ville
non pourquoi pas ce que je préfère le
pétard ah bon
parce que ça fait moins grossir notre
bonne question grossir c'est que je suis
pas gommé fais quoi moi ouais ouais tu
vois plus du tout en ce moment plus du
tout du tout mais en mangeant du bois
quoi du lait écrémé de l'eau de l'eau tu
fumes plus non plus si tu fumes quand
même plus pourquoi à part les pétards
toutes les marques mais ça fait pas des
scandales et m'a dit viens tu baisses
beaucoup en ce moment mais je m'occupe
de mai et toi tu te bras le corps et
avec quelles mains devant le toit alors
et le doigt avec elle te plaît
tu peux pas de la télé en posant des
questions est ce que tu fais du sport
non piano comme ça c'est tout inutile de
te demander si tu vas là roland garros
tu t'en fous de roland garros mais tais
toi moi oui mais alors mon fils ah bon
il est branché tu sais si tu demandes à
machin j'ai tu peux le faire dans les
pétroles un moment les passeports en six
mois c'est que si moi qui me fais le
poste en fait on est tous à l'affectif
mans et puis parce que je veux voir
jennifer capriati jennifer capriati qui
fait un choix que ça cause la culotte
d'approché compris
enfin bon alors ici si on va aller voir
un bon final dames c'est à dire à l'âge
qu'il a dit moi toi quand tu es petit tu
étais pas ramasseuse de balle si tu
t'étais ramasseuse de balle ouais bah tu
ferais un côté chapet mais non c'est
vrai mais est terrorisée par les plus
grands qui n'est bon les petits oiseaux
tennis et tout et on était obligé de
c'est vrai que quand tu étais petit on
tape les attila c'est vrai qu'on a dû
changer dix fois l'établissement
seulement ouais on était au cachot il
part elles n'ont pas caché pas les
cacher non se foutait on officier
enfermé à clef
voilà dans une pièce et puis quand tu
t'énerves est un peu forcément c'est de
les revendre calmez vous mais vous êtes
tous ça te calmes ça
non non on te jeter de l'eau froide
dessus c'est vrai oui pour calmer pour
se calmer tout est là la seule réponse
finalement à cet isolement social c'est
qu'à l'époque c'est là qu'il a commencé
à te dire je serai ses lettres je serai
célèbre c'est la demande et ça l'a
prouvé qu'elle colle avec thor quoi
alors que c'est ça non mais ça l'école
j'ai pas changé d'avis ouais je suis
effondré c'est marrant tête et rebelles
très jeune finalement non mais c'est à
dire c'était même par e mail j'étais
allergique
on m'a mis à l'école j'ai commencé un
eczéma purulent des réalisera en tête
jusque là avec des croûtes et des trucs
mais je passe le bac 3 jours après guéri
tu vois et l'âge de 15 ans tu décides
d'été de t'inscrire dans un cours d'art
dramatique et or là il ya deux versions
quand on lit les articles ont été écrits
sur toi août les interviews il y en a où
tu dis tu es parents étaient d'accord et
d'autres utilités parents n'étaient pas
d'accord alors il sait d'accord ou pas
d'accord des parents ils m'ont forcé en
france la femme a choisi
et là tu t'es inscrits jbe il a tu as
commencé à traîner à saint germain
c'était à la fin des fins des années 60
ouais milieu des années 60 les années 70
j'ai une magie
ouais tu fais très très très très jolie
déjà et c'est là que tu as rencontré ta
première famille d'adoption
c'est la bande de jean pierre kalfon pas
est ce que j'aime et oui ben oui les
bactéries pis ça se passe et comment
cette époque alors bien des raisons la
caméra histoire le temps que ce qui
s'avère très très bien à quoi tu occupes
toi tu es journées assez libéré
oui et on est sorti de la praye détendu
quoi ouais tu sais quoi pour libérer
alors alors on se libéraient des des
idéologies bourgeoise fait un premier
point donc par exemple et on avait deux
qui voulait faire un enfant puis parce
qu'on était c'était une bonne
extrêmement convivial parce qu'il veut
s'il vivait de la place de la libération
sexuelle dont où il fallait quand même
ça c'est mes sens développe peace and
love
ouais bon que la grande et comme on
avait pas mal de matelas comme ça bon et
alors un jeu il y en a deux qui disent
qu'ils vont faire un enfant
alors il consulte appelle la communauté
v10 et comment tu l'appellera and on
l'appellera passé bourges a donné un nom
quand même très en profondeur
quand tu dis à l'époque j'ai beaucoup
traîné un coup j'étais entretenu par un
mec un coup il y avait un copain qui me
prêtait du pognon serait beaucoup de
couples ces accrocs maintenant on se
libère et moi j'avais à coeur de
mais oui c'est à dire qu'on a un système
de sécurité fonctionnent entre nous
comme personne n'avait tapié du conte
polio pas d'impôts l'ont chargé comme ça
alors
et c'était genre combien 13 s'emballe
bon alors tu m'invite à dîner ben oui
tiens j'ai pas tu n'attends qui pourrait
me faire bouffer soit mon fils à moi je
suis comme ça toi ont partagé tous tu
veux on partage est vraiment vraiment
tout mais c'était pas le truc vicelard
je me sens très mal c'est vrai c'était
on était en train de changer le monde
quand même car ne l'oublions pas est ce
que le monde nous a changé est ce que le
monde nous a changé certains d'entre
nous et non non jamais une parce que je
trouve extraordinaire de toi tu dis à
l'époque j'étais un petit animal
sexuelle joliff tâche c'est vraiment
être massé jolie un rongeur un petit à
petit elle qu elle sait que je peux dire
quoi au juste
pourtant j'étais déjà grande amitié sans
même animal
ça n'a pas changé sexuelle bah oui
c'était très partage oui tu as peur du
sida aujourd'hui away peur peur peur
peur dont l'enfant oui quand même
enfin je dirais l'est pas il va pas
s'arrêter en me disant que j'ai tout ça
tu vas enfin bon oui mais oui ça tu as
raison c'était la grande différence
tu as fait ton test oui alors à tuchan
bas de quoi je vais pas du tabriz que tu
t'en vas et tu devrais rencontrer 7h été
pourri un bon 67
tu as tourné son premier film de
philippe garrel j'avais 17 ans il en
avait 19 et ça s'appelait anne aymone
n'at il pas très fameux effet quoi
rester un film de jeunes tu as rue de
pin film oui et alors abbès et
ces jeunes pas où je m'étais lancé dans
une espèce de composition parce que je
voulais je voulais jouer une bourgeoise
comme dans les films de brisson je
parlais légèrement faux et en 68 tu
occupes l'odéon
ah bah oui qu'est ce qui se passait à
l'odéon je te raconte pour les jeunes
générations gaulle est alors moins de
deux ans à moi ouais ça commence comme
ça un jour il ya kalfon qui me dit anne
aymone on veut occuper l'odéon alors
comme forcément va être encerclée donc
il va falloir aller chercher des vivres
pour remplir le déan de vivre je sais
bon va falloir trouver lapointe
bouillante et tout en avant l' aventure
on va chez castel donc comme ça dix
roquettes pour acheter des vivres pour
la prise de l'odéon plus alors yapo
lorsqu'il faut jouer plus il y avait un
bus buffalan tout le monde donne de
l'argent pinon avec ail et puis on
notait machin la mi temps et tout puis
tout paris des filets etc
avant la prise et le dur alors marc de
venise qui était excité comme une puce
qui allaient chercher des grands par
vous un tapis du whisky ça peut pas
faire de mal et on partait avec les bons
et puis un jour qu'elles font arriver
que la deux chevaux puis ça y est ça y
est l'audio et prix tagada et en france
en réalité c'était pas vraiment un siège
avant toi bon c'est à dire on avait à
manger normalement
et puis
et puis il y avait plein de costumes qui
traînaient partout j'ai hérité chez plus
comment d'une d'une robe de chambre
sûrement d'un marivaux alors après je
partage je ne porte plus que ça toi
toute la journée
match à tout ça et c'était gai qu'est-ce
qu'on arrive alors là elle après tu es
parti de 69 à 62 28 parties trois ans tu
parti aux états unis pour suivre un
peintre dont tu étais très amoureuse
puis l'a laissé tomber sans un rond non
c'est à dire il me n'êtes pas alors jt
avait le coeur brisé alors sur tric
ouais bah tu t'es balader tafer
marrakech en fin d'année la route un peu
et quand tu es revenue en france c'était
en 72 et tu étais assez déçu parce que
tu te disais les gens sont tous en train
de mourir de de drogue ou d'idéologie
c'est à dire mais moi je
mais pas mourir pour moi j'ai trouvé le
début des années 70 la période baba cool
quand c'est le moment où les gens ont
commencé à découvrir ses idées mais un
peu tape d'une façon qui étaient
autrement etc
je trouve cette triste ces années là
mais tu risques
c'est l'acte a décidé de partir à reims
sur scène et jouer phèdre et ut aperçu
que quand tu jouais fèves des gens
rigolaient alors là c'est là que j'ai
rencontré la bande du splendid l'état
reverse n 15 et 75 d'état carrière
démarrée toujours pas bien et tu as dit
à ce moment là si je suis pas célèbre à
30 ans je me tue vraiment à 10 à 25 ans
qui comme à 25 ans tu étais pas ce qui a
poussé jusqu'à trois manières non mais
non c'est à dire que c'est vrai que j'ai
des copains en fait à l'origine qui
m'avait dit parce que c'est angoissant
de vouloir faire métier de pas y arriver
et puis me dit mais tu sais je t'assure
si c'est une question de vie ou de mort
tu y arrivera ouais je suis bon dans une
question si jamais j'arrive pas je meurs
ça que je fais ouais où il est justement
parlant de feu aux fesses tu t'es
retrouvée enceinte
ouais tu savais pas de quel sein du tout
faire exprès sinon quoi
oui j'ai fini par trouver un nom du
cinéma oui 23e régiment de paris
et c'est là miracle là c'est le miracle
quand même eu un miracle
tu as rencontré philippe galland qui a
été l'homme de ta vie pendant de longues
années et tu fais le père noël est une
ordure qui a été ton premier gros succès
en fait gagner chez moi d'abord bien
chez moi dans ma cuisine comme celle là
tu es une vraie parce qu'après il y ait
de sucre elle j'avais des grands rôles
qui tel le père noël le quart d'heure ma
femme s'appelle reviens et puis je suis
père est quatrième après justin bieber
s'était vedette et là tu te paye le luxe
de faire en plus des choses de qualité
d'envoyer chier tout le monde était
capricieuse a quand même à l'époque
non non non c'est une grande fille mais
jamais été capricieuse le coût des césar
quand même c'était un peu qu'après ça
peut être cette année soral qui disait
moi je viens convaincu mais faut qu'on
roule un patin en même temps
mais quel rapport avec les césar c'est
sa raison que tu as eu sa rapport avec
ça si tu veux c'est à dire qu'à un
moment donné tu te retrouves à faire une
émission qui à l'époque faisait encore
un tout petit peu d'audience et c'est
assez un créneau publicité à ça semble
quand même bon mais le créneau
publicitaire normalement donc tu fais ça
pour le producteur
mais si vraiment le producteur il t'a
rien donné qu'est ce que tu vas lui
faire un cadeau de savoir plus car c'est
lié à l'état foutu le bordel
non j'ai parlé de mes bijoux de mes
robes de mes affaires je veux ta pub à
toi ouais alors d'accord c'est ça
l'histoire
enfin tiens regarde sa plume pimp l'onf
une pile ce soir
bon d accord
le soir les soirs des césar où tu avais
été donc meilleure actrice se 87 je
crois pour le grand chemin de jean louis
hubert c'est ça tu étais au sommet
c'était génial de faire ça tout les
fillettes ont de leur césar comme ça
pendant des années toi tu arrives tu
fout le bordel tu fais la pub de ton
copain qui fait les bijoux etc
tu sais j'avais les chocottes un de
faire ça parce que à l'époque c'était je
t'assure c'était carpet ce métier
maintenant ça bouge un peu
y'a pas nouveau film de john barry plein
de trucs qui bougent et tout mais je
suis sûr qu'il ya eu un moment dans les
années 80 les années reagan tout était
figé le pognon c'était tout était riche
et gagnant à l'arrêt total et bien ou
sinon tu étais la lie de l'humanité
c'était d'une moquerie complètement
faire quoi et moi j'avais super les
chocottes parce que genre tu es dans un
ciel serein tout s'appuie d'ailleurs
j'ai pas été déçu du voyage prévu
beaucoup de travail et dans le système
de mazel paraît qu'on en parle encore 10
mois est ce que tu crois que les gens
dans la rue savent ce que tu as été
obligé de faire pour y arriver
et là j'aurais bien aimé coup chèques
des producteurs mais il préfère me faire
travailler pour rester dans la politique
aux dernières élections
tu as voté la longue veste heures tu as
raison j'étais embêté alors je ne veux
pas qu'ils se disputent je voudrais
adresser un message à tous les deux
réconciliez vous je ne me retrouve plus
alors j'étais obligé avec des petits
bulletins de fer am stram gram comme ça
et j'aimerais dans l'enveloppé je ne
sais pas ce qui est bien c'est pas à non
je faisais comme ça je dois ce pour toi
seul et même pour moi l'écologie doit
être une grande famille comme le cinéma
ça va être beau dis moi le sommet de la
terre à rio la baisse qu'on nous rabat
les oreilles en ce moment tu vois que ça
va changer quelque chose
pas tout de suite non mais c'est un bon
départ et c'est qu'en nouvelle zélande
il commence déjà à pas empêché les
enfants des écoles de sortir à certaines
heures se protéger du soleil etc
ça a commencé à ça le savate bientôt au
canada tous les pays près du pôle
non mais ça nos enfants ni comprend pas
des terrains au soleil avec les bulles
bah oui c'est ça le cancer de la peau
c'est la fin du monde c'est pas la fin
du monde on est une espèce prend
différentes donc il va en rester un
petit paquet je prends sera bien content
concrètement tu fais quoi toi pour
l'écologie quantité dans le bordelais
par exemple qu'est ce tu as fait pour
l'écossé pendant plus de ben ouais quand
j'étais à bordeaux à caen j'avais mieux
pour un circuit et ne pas savoir
alors j'avais les deux poubelles j'avais
même les trois poubelles
qu'est ce qu'il avait dans ses poubelles
à la yann hovine avec les plastiques
on va tout ce qui n'est pas
biodégradable il y en avait une avec le
bois le papier mais ça l'est dans la
cheminée
il y en avait une avec les déchets
alimentaires alors ce qu'ils étaient il
y avait le chien du voisin
absorbé une partie est le résultat à
courir dans un petit hors mélanger des
buttes de derb et tous puis après tu as
pourri peut présumer dans le jardin ça
fait quoi d'autre pour l'écologie pour
l'environnement dans le bordelais il
voulait faire passer à travers la forêt
de léojac qui est la plus belle forêt du
vin qui est le plus joli coin le peut
dudu du sauternais tu vois qu'un endroit
ravissent avec des vieux village et au
il voulait te tailler là dedans je sais
pas quoi 30 km de large et en avant
marche pour les exporter de
l'électricité à l'espagne mais ce n'est
qu'un fonctionnaire à toulouse avec la
règle et le papier c'est pas méchant le
type aulas à fabien drouet d'avis europe
tu vois la prônait talent et d'expliquer
que non c'est vachement joli ici on l'a
dit pourquoi vous passez pas à côté de
l'autoroute c'est déjà tout gâcher ce
foutu il ya bien la place ça va être
formidable à côté de l'autoroute
ils nous ont répandu aux gens vous
rendez compte on va pas détruire le
paysage de l'autoroute bon alors là vu
que l'on thorel mais c'est à dire que
les tours toile moi j'ai jamais été
contre la chasse je suis trouve que la
chasse c'est très très bien c'est un
beau sport comme c'est bien pratique et
sur un gibier à l'automne pourquoi parce
que le jb s'est reproduit donc il est
plus nombreux quand c'est à gibier
migrateur c'est avant la migration et
des composés de son été il est gras on
peut le manger
bah oui c'est ça quand même hein c'est
pas la peine d'aller tuer pour ça je
déteste les chasseurs qui tire à la
mitrailleuse qui jettent ensuite nous
vraiment dégueulasse mais si c'est pour
manger c'est parfait la tourterelle ça
ne se mange pas elle est toute maigre
quand elle arrive c'est le printemps
elle n'a pas encore fait ses bébés
chaque fois que tu une femelle tutu 4
d'être elle est un peu on va disposer au
moins une espèce menacée dont toutes ces
raisons la fin que je suis évidemment
contre la chasse à la tourterelle quitte
une chasse barbare et qui insulte à la
chasse en fin de compte je vais
retourner tous les ans avec sophie
marceau et bougrain dubourg fait si
j'avais dix-sept années que j'y
retournerais puis j'étais pas là et
alors oui j'aimerais bien retourner mais
bon mais en même temps je trouve qu'il
faut pas non plus c'est vraiment leur
petit cache la forêt ça parce que
premièrement faut savoir qu'il ya 90 %
toutes espèces confondues
90% des oiseaux d'europe qui ont disparu
qui sont mort tu vois il leur reste plus
que 10 % et c'est pas à cause des
chasseurs ainsi à cause de la
disparition du biotope autrement dit les
bétonneurs la pollution les insecticides
la disparition des forêts de leur gîte
et c est bon c'est ça qui crée la
disparition des oiseaux les pauvres
chasseurs mais dockal je te dire ils
sont une poignée et
parce que les jeunes il y retourne pas
la chasse adopterait tu crois que c'est
vraiment un concours photo de patients
et boivent beaucoup il vise pas toujours
comment ils semblent se termine à rieux
merville
alors on a vu un petit peu toute ta vie
ton premier enfant ton deuxième enfant
le deuxième enfant c'était philippe
galère pas parler de ma naissance nom
n'a pas parlé non pas une prochaine une
prochaine édition
avec les violences vous n'êtes pas
mariée finalement toi tu voulais te
marier mais à l'église
lui voulait pas c'est à dire que moi
j'ai toujours eu un rêve et déjà j'avais
fini par aller voir le curé de saint
sulpice à ce sujet ouais parce que
j'aurais voulu me marier elle est c'est
à dire cérémonie sans mariage me marier
à l'église sans passer par la mairie
parce que la mairie c'est que des
papiers et des problèmes des emmerdes
tandis que l'église effectivement c'est
très rare
je lis je suis allé voir le curé je lui
dis voilà séparation de l'église et de
l'état
ç'a eu lieu en 1905 normalement rien ne
s'oppose mais oui mathilde et rien ne
s'oppose donc jeu
en principe on doit pouvoir se marier
j'ai bien regretter ce alors oui
l'europe centrale est hachurée popcap a
voulu au final cure il était de voir ce
que j'habite à un peu hâte et quand même
au dessus non non mais j'ai tout fait
pour me marier dans l'immédiat c'était
pour avoir un enseignement
dans 85 après ça faisait quoi six ans de
vie commune
vous avez décidé de faire un appartement
à part non mais c'est vrai que si on
parle du problème du divorce en général
c'est vrai que moi je pense que on
devrait dire que quand on fait des
gosses sont en pente pour 25 ans et puis
que effectivement les deux appartements
lance chaque indien beauté d'un palier
ou deux étages différents c'est une
solution
il y avait une petite fille de parents
divorcés qui disait mais moi j'en ai
marre
pourquoi est-ce que c'est pas moi qui
suis dans l'appartement et puis vous qui
venez chacun votre tour ne sait vraiment
ce qu pas mal mais oui c'est terrible
pour les enfants d'avoir déménagé papa
la maman là et c'est bon tu es content
le divorce en gros c'est à dire je ne
suis pas contre que chacun reprenne sa
vie privée et puis mais je n'ai en effet
je trouve que c'est mieux oui de jolo
dicté contre l'idée de rester amis quoi
pour les enfants sans hésiter contre
l'idée de massacrer des enfants pour
découvrir de petits plaisirs qui
finalement finiront par s'user alors
tout ce que je sais que ya deux façons
de voir les choses ya la bonne vision
française faisait d'une bonne vision
française de toute l'époque classique on
disait papa lance marie c'est pour
élever les enfants puis si on s'entend
pas bon on fait de chacun seront faits
changera pas et on a sa vie puis on
n'évoque pas de jaloux s'emmerder avec
des histoires et on élève des enfants
c'est ça qu'on se trouvait d'affaires
est aussi ça veut dire toi alors divorce
alors on recommence et de nouveau le
grand amour et on refait des enfants et
puis bon le grand amour la passion
chérie je t'aime c'est pour la vie on
sait très bien que c'est pourquoi trois
en sept ans
non et puis c'est tout alors puisqu'on
le sait pour compte et tout ça tu aimes
tu es enfant tu as un petit peu sacrifié
sa carrière annonce a dit toujours la
même un petit peu sacrifié ta carrière
quand ils les vivent dans le bordelais
parce que c'est pour eux calé dans le
bordelais mais c'était beaucoup pour eux
mais malgré tout c'est à dire que c'est
vrai que les enfants qui décident
d'aider carré pour voir leur dis
dessiner un poisson et dessine les 40
années et un macbook aux il avait malgré
tout tu dis quand même que tes enfants
maintenant tu les as tu fais tout pour
eux tu veux tu aller vivre dans le
bordelais un petit peu pour eux mais
malgré tout tu dis que tu les a eus par
accident ses enfants tu dis que tu as
été victime du mythe de la femme
reproductrices à qui on explique depuis
qu'elle est toute petite qu'elle doit
avoir des enfants c'est vrai que les
femmes trouvent en faisait des enfants
ne réfléchissez pas devant mais 0,9 et
1,7 à proposer les enfants ont pu
l'appeler lui est arrivé et puis mais la
pilule est arrivé mais les mentalités
ont continué à être pour être une femme
épanouie et tout le monde s'y être une
vraie femme je dire toutes les semaines
on fait des enfants alors que si on
commence à élever les filles
différemment en leur disant tu sais
attention les enfants c'est un boulot
c'est une vocation c'est très
particulier à travailler à temps complet
qui demande d'un tas de compétences qui
demandent du coc s'y adonnent qu'on se
passionne pour ça et c'est alors donc
réfléchi mais on peut aussi envisager
d'ailleurs de dire défi qui dit moi je
les fais puis c'est d'autres filles qui
les élève comme par exemple les
africains qui vivent tribu ça fait des
enfants 13 qui libre et parce qu'ils ont
toutes sortes de ya plein de gens autour
d'eux donc ils peuvent choisir avec qui
vont se sentant dit qu'il va leur
apporter tout ça mais c'est vrai que la
façon dont on vit en ville avec les
femmes au boulot les mecs qui malgré
tout
100 en [ __ ] une tout à fait rire mais
bon faut pas grand chose et que help et
le pit le manque de crèches les horaires
les mecs ils disent qu'ils mettent la
main à la pâte mais il paraît qu'ils
vous aident leurs bonnes femmes 10
minutes de plus 400 ans
je savais ce qu'il ya 20 ans on m'avait
dit qu'en 20 ans du sionisme et hurle la
diminution gedi mérite de plus les
minutes ou les vingt ans ça fait pas
lourd
c'est énorme comme ils montrent pas de
contentieux a dit que tu avais avorté tu
lui a déclaré sans beaucoup de
l'immobilité d'ailleurs tu dis que c'est
un petit peu comme tuer des des petits
chatons ça fait froid dans le dos c'est
réciproque
non mais je veux dire non mais c'est à
dire que parce que moi j'ai connu quand
même l'époque où c'est interdit
alors bon c'est vrai qu'en mai après on
devient provoque ce que vous ferez
exagéré tu vis seule la et toi non
je suis désolé je suis marié blais
l'équipe
ouais j'aimerais bien j'ai lancé un
appel sur les ondes
j'aimerais bien un jour être demoiselle
d'honneur tu as dis dans ma génération
il n'y a pas un homme pour racheter
l'autre tu crois que tu vas rester
célibataire longtemps
non je n'ai parlé que de ma génération
il voudra m'interdit maginea si tu veux
des adresses l'on s'arrache à vinci
[Musique]
des moines est ce que tu crois péché
originel à temps pistone à la rubrique
pêcher et à un péché qui doit être
original parce que je le fais tout le
temps et qui est que je ne vends que de
moi tonnes et j'oublie toujours on me
dit alors le metteur en scène ça deviens
antoine on le met en scène de la pièce
et daniel benoin et sept faits s'étaient
produits à la comédie de saint-etienne
et alors il faut le dire c'est le genre
qui fait qu'on fait c'est d'un premier
péché oui oui c'est ça non ça il fallait
pas non maintenant que je suis tout bien
nettoyer toute trace de prêcher non ce
n'est pas le péché d'orgueil c'est le
péché du bo centrisme rothen un péché
dire s'il n'avait pas eu le centriste uc
voilà ouais parce que tu pêches par
avarice annonça j'aimerais bien alors là
qu'est ce que j'aimerais bien
après est-ce que tu pêches par
gourmandise ah non c'est pas gourmande
non autant de faits bien comme ça pas
mal je me démerde non je suis pas très
bon non
est ce que tu peux je pars en vies
croisées m'est arrivé c'est pas toi je
virtuosité comprend pas tout les pauvres
non ça m'est arrivé venir ma soeur par
exemple c'était l'oeuvre
je tu ils pèchent par colère rarement un
ca faut vraiment non je suis pas
tellement en colère vous un bon outil
jusqu'à présent la charge mais chapeau
parfait à charm el-cheikh veilleuse la
paresse la wii la pâte à pain de des
monologues d'humeur parker s'est pas de
l'appareil si parce que c'est j'apprends
tout servi mais non là je suis fait
masser comme i am et tous les tirs une
première tout tu vois ce genre si je
peux éviter mais je sais pas moi de
passer l'épongé sur l'interprète de
miettes j'éviterai tu veux ce bien sûr
ah oui tout en photo à la paresse plus
quand je pense que les invités rupture à
l'école mais il a calé et je n'empêche
pas il ne ternit pas contester devant
germain
bon on passe l'épongé ce que tu pêches
par l'udc sur l'autre enfin le samedi
est ce que tu crois en dieu dieu
directement dieu non mais alors
effectivement c'est au nom les progrès
de la science puisse qu'ils en arrivent
à dire que après le big bang lors la
façon dont l'univers s'est créé et
organisé ne peut pas contrairement à ce
que croient y est mono ya quelques
années être le fruit du hasard
voilà il ya trop de coïncidences c'est à
dire c'est la science qui ramène à
l'aide des dieux ou du moins de 2
qu'elle essaie d'ouvrir cette
organisation quoi et au diable lui croit
au diable non c'est alors j ai jamais
cru mamalépot vous croyez en dieu
on reçoit maintenant à limone comment ça
elle est même nous donner ses tourments
wister baffie a tout raconté bien
alors merci d'être là parce que vous
détestez un peu la promo enfin vous
l'avez beaucoup dit en tous les cas un
donc salière ya pas marqué marche forme
de film c'était pas le métier que j'ai
marqué mais les revendeurs m'enfin on
est content de vous on est content de
vous accueillir vous avez une fois c'est
une comédie qui fait rire anémone vous
êtes resté au delà toutes ces années
utopiste un peu peu marginal un peu un
peu baba cool on peut dire non un peu
desesperado en même temps la cool non
pas par défaut moi j'étais papa aussi
voilà maintenant mal côté pull-over
tricoté en lettres des pyrénées c'est
sûr il est resté quand même
marginalement faire nettement jean
claude gauthier martin dé leur père à
dos anonyme je suis papa desperados mai
c'est à dire j'ai commencé à tellement
de faire chier dans ce milieu on n'y a
que je suis allé voir ailleurs si vous y
était et vous n'y étiez pas donc c'était
bien c'était le bonheur
alors c'est vrai que vos coups de gueule
vous ont écarté des studios ou c'est
simplement que justement parce que vous
aviez plus envie de voir la gueule des
gens ici où c'est un peu vous le fait
que se tient un peu insupportable sur
les plateaux de cinéma
non mais c'est aussi c'est parce que
c'est une vie qu'il coûte très cher de
la vie nomade
non on peut jamais rien prévoir il vous
change des trucs tout le temps bon donc
ça coûte très cher après y aller les
toute façon vous triche un peu ensuite
les impôts vous matraque et où je me
suis rendu compte qu'au fond je vivais
mieux si je travaillais pas oui au
bonheur comme c'est ma passion
number one de rien [ __ ] non monsieur
ça vous emmerdez commercial de faire la
star sandwich pour les couturiers les
sphères des dif thing aller au gala se
bourrer la gueule ça vous ça vous ça
vous gaver pour pour être clair non non
mais c'est vrai j'ai pas choisi comme
métier ni vendeuse de film sandwich mais
moi je voulais être actrice bon depuis
quand on m'a expliqué que l'actrice
était tout ça est bas bon alors donc
d'inscrire le fait mais vous regrettez
pas quand même quand vous voyez le
succès des jugnot des claviers des
lhermitte des blanchons quand même
bourré aux as quoi ça vous avoue que je
suis papa c'est pas un peu envieuse de
menace que moi je suis tombé dedans
quand j'étais petit donc je sais depuis
ma naissance que l'argent ne fait pas le
bruit
c'est vrai que votre famille avec peu
d'argent ben oui un petit peu d'argent
donc c'est pour ça que je m'en fous je
pense que quand on est né dans le pognon
peut pas y attacher de l'importance ou
alors on est gravement tard et quoi moi
ya quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup choqué
réservé aux ignorants et eau et aux gens
qui sont nés dans la poubelle de
s'allumer que ces conneries là j'ai des
âmes par exemple vous êtes linverse
d'année matière elle est née avec du
pognon alors veut plus vous vous êtes né
sans pognon et vous avez beaucoup
travaillé pour devenir star en avoir
ouais bien sûr mais je suis d'accord
avec elle
c'est vrai que peu voire beaucoup de
pognon et pas être heureux quoi mais
j'essaie de ne pas me tourner la tête
non plus j'aurais juste posé une colle
jamais manqué de rien à notre côté
attention attention j'ai assuré de rien
on a les bonnes gens juste poser une
question pourquoi vous avez refusé le
votre césar parce que ça m'a marqué à la
télé mais je les ai je vais oublier
vraiment un
je vous jure que c'est vrai bon personne
ne me croira tout le monde rit comme
l'anr entendu j'ai vraiment oublier le
truc mais d'un autre côté concernant il
foutu s'est jamais qu'un nid à poussière
zaïm donc le refrain lab ou bien alors
moi j'ai quelque chose à bonn quand même
qui m'a un petit peu choqué c'est que
vous dites à un moment donné de votre
vie vous regrettez d'avoir faire vos
enfants je regrette d'avoir fait des
enfants mais je pense que c'est si
c'était maintenant pour que en réalité
c'est une espèce de contraintes
intérieures parce que les femmes de ma
génération vous pourrez tellement le mou
depuis l'enfance avec ces histoires de
princes charmants et d'enfants et
c'était un étudiant et un horizon
indépassable et que moi je pense que
tout le monde n'est pas n'a pas la
vocation
maternelle je pense est une évocation
tout à fait particulière et qu'en
réalité on devrait élever les femmes de
telle sorte qu'elle est vraiment le
choix et je pense pas qu'on ait tout
fait pour avoir des enfants c'est le
conseil que vous donnez à votre fille
aujourd'hui saison absolument moi je dis
à ma fille si tu te sens vraiment la
vocation maternelle vas-y foncé je
t'aiderai mais si tu as envie de faire
autre chose te sens pas obligé parce
qu'être mère sait pas c'est pas une
obligation pour toutes les femmes très
bien merci à lemon ne souhaitait pas
intervenir
très bien alors dans vous êtes ici pour
l'homme de ma vie qui est un film de
stéphane curc sortie le 22 septembre
avec patrick chesnais bruno solo
marianne denicourt jean claude brialy et
vous alors le sujet on peut dire en 2001
c'est charles qui est jouée par solo qui
va avoir un petit qui tenait une
relation fusionnelle avec son
psychanalyste est tellement fusionnel
que d'ailleurs le psychanalyste c'est
une scène qui me fait beaucoup rire ou
le psychanalyste attaque à la hache
l'apport de son client c'est très drôle
bien alors maintenant on va passer à la
dernière rubrique de l'émission dernier
jeu de l'émission s'est enfoncé bougeait
pas
[Musique]
normalement tu vas bientôt ressentent
une bonne éducation parce que je pense
de suite de quoi puis après tu ne bouges
plus tabou j'ai un petit peu les yeux
mais bon alors le principe ça s'appelle
personne ne m'en vous connaissez le
principe c'est le jeu de la vérité
donc on a un soir avec des amis on a un
peu bu et on décide de se dire la vérité
toute la vérité d'accord alors je veux
bien commencé mais chacun peut poser des
questions aux autres est ce qu'on peut
baisser serge la lumière s'il te plaît
j'ai le jeu de la vérité tu connais oui
oui ça me rappelle des souvenirs
on se dit la vraie vérité ça me réveille
des souvenirs de colo quand on arrête de
type au crédit la vérité toute la vérité
toute nue
oui l'état à l'époque des colos c'était
l'occasion dire et alors est ce que tu
mènes voilà est-ce que finalement on
peut dire en conclusion programme takata
carrière ta vie depuis trente ans que tu
n'as pas voulu rentrer dans le rang tu
as toujours voulu rester marginal et est
ce que t'as pas le sentiment quand même
qu'à cause de ça tu as un peu raté ta
vie
alors vous dit tout ouais j'ai vachement
raté mon compte en banque mais comme une
encore une fois ce n'était pas le plus
important
un nom que moi mon ambition dans la vie
c'était de me marrer un grosso merdo j'y
suis à peu près arrivé à éviter les
écueils et to dream on l'empêché
franchement avant ce jeu la vérité là
francis est ce que vous ne regrettez pas
finalement
50e la cinquantaine comme ça ne pas
avoir essayé les mecs n'ont fini tsahal
est finie bonjour maintenant à rawdon tu
peux aussi posé toit des questions aux
gens qui sont là c'est le principe j'ai
pas à parler tout le temps j'ai une
question à poser à christine passé comme
je l'aï dit tout à l'heure je trouve que
c'est une personne attachante et c'est
vrai que quand on sait qu'on va le
rencontrer on se dit qu il monte un peu
et c'est vrai que tu as dit beaucoup
beaucoup de conneries pour moi la plus
grosse c'est de ne pas accepter
l'homosexualité de la montrer du doigt
comme étant une tare physique tu va à
l'encontre de l'évolution du monde les
choses sont comme ça qu'ils passent les
que les couples homos passe à la mairie
ou pas ça tu n'arrêtera pas la marche du
temps est ce que tu te rends compte
malgré ta sincérité que tu dis parfois
des conneries énorme mais ce n'était pas
un petit peu prisonnière de ton
personnage médiatisée aux gestionnaires
son personnage qui est jetée sans doute
autant de conneries que toi certainement
mais moi j'ai eu c'est mon boulot moi la
différence de toi c'est que et c'est
peut-être là où je suis idiote
peut-être que je me trompe mais c'est
vrai que moi j'ai un certain nombre de
certitudes c'est à dire que le bo n'est
pas égal ou l'est pour moi il ya un bien
il ya un mal je sais ce que c'est alors
je peux me tromper mais gégé cette
certitude que sa sacrée bien l'âme une
question vous avez envie de poser à
quelques uns ici est très très sincère
puisque cette heure-là il est tellement
tard que tout le monde dit la vérité
francis est ce que tu écoutes un peu à
la radio
la connais je sais faire la réponse est
malheureusement que le sport foot mais
tu n'as pas compris ce que je disais
tout à l'heure c'est physiquement
j'étais entendu mais physique j ai
jamais mais pas du tout oui mais oui
bien sûr moi j'ai une question pour
francis encore justement dans l'une des
émissions vous étiez présent l'autre
jour je vous ai vu avec votre petit
chien scaramouche là je voudrais savoir
si à force de jouer étaient des variétés
vous être appelée le syndrome belmondo
qui se baladent parfait que son chien
j'espère c'est super sympa on a toujours
l'impression justement quand on a un
chien que ça veut dire qu'on est
efféminé mais c'est complètement je veux
dire c'est un chien pour moi c'est ainsi
un être humain je veux dire si c'est
incroyable il ya 350 mots vraiment je
les vérifier il est là non il est pas la
vub à terme non mais c'est vrai qu'ils
comprennent vraiment aux 10 des mots il
est complet tout à fait je suis une
question c'est une question très piège
vous me jurez de répondre vraiment non
non non écouter c'est très simple en
fonction de tout ce qui a été dit un
homme et un homme qui vivent ensemble
qui s'aiment humainement moralement
sexuellement
ils se font du bien ou du mal je ne sais
pas moi je pense que deux hommes qui
s'aiment et deux femmes qui s'aiment
moralement physiquement se font du bien
alors anémone vous ne faites pas partie
de l'équipe des bronzés 3 non ce qui
vous permet de venir à la télé parle est
votre spectacle au théâtre des variétés
après tout c'est pas plus mal
1 mais vous avez vous êtes fâché avec
eux nous avons un petit différend dont
on ne va pas reparler comme ça pendant
150 ans voilà l affaire est classée y
avait des répliques à vous dans le père
noël est une ordure et
et j'ai pas eu les souks elle est avec
et ça m'a énervé voilà basta bombail est
surtout quand c'est désolant c'est un
peu une trahison c'est vrai c'est
terrible ça oui c'est terrible ça y est
ce vécu s'est passé s'est dit j'ai séché
en tout cas ça vous permet ça vous
permet de rencontrer pierre lellouche le
futur maire de paris donc voilà un abo
rougeole là et alors qu'est ce qui nous
attends tu viens me donne donc les
bagnoles par exemple à les bagnoles
oui j'ai supprimé entièrement bas au
maximum en tout cas si ça vous fait rien
et vous allez vous déplacer comment et
bien alors j'ai fait du vélo bonne idée
alors je prédis vais je ferai du vélo
s'ils avaient plus de bagnoles
effectivement s'il y avait le réseau
vert vous avez entendu ce trophée
delanoë c'est le mois de décembre là il
y avait une réunion dans le sixième jeu
télé voire de la mairie attention parce
que les terribles et elle et lui a dit
mais le réseau vers des simply stylet ou
et tout un oui c'est un truc bête qui
est de dire attendez bon les bagnoles
elles ont plein dax pour se déplacer
partout et pourquoi est ce que nous mais
grâce au ciel merci delanoë merci
delanoë ben là dessus mais en tout cas
on aimerait bien nous les piétons les
vélos les poussettes les rollers les
jeunes c'est quoi vous savez cimentation
absolument cheval
je laisse les cages pour les touristes
oui alors le pousse-pousse croyez pas
s'il veut revivre ça revient vous savez
les surfeurs se faire des muscles et
tout ça un peu d'argent de poche
alors ils font le pousse pousse à vélo
alors ils ont le tricycle derrière vous
êtes et les autres qui sont la muscu et
bon ben on essaie de voile à olaizola
toutes sortes de ses passagers de la
voiture j'ai pour les étudiants qui
veulent oui absolument absolument c'est
une façon de résoudre le chômage aussi
alors également
alors c'est vrai alors une très bonne
façon de résoudre le chômage
revenons à l'agriculture biologique et
gourmand d'alamderi nom pareil on ne
serait pas là avance à bon monsieur
maintenant que je les avais des
ambitions présidentielles non non mais
lordon racontez-moi l'agriculture les
cultures biologiques et les gourmands
bras
en réalité si vous voulez l'agriculture
biologique c'est à dire la grippe
traditionnelle en agro en écosystème
intégré ça c'est le mot savant produit
trois fois plus de nourriture en tonnage
à l'hectare que la monoculture ne
parlons pas des ogm qui font baisser
encore les rendements de 10 % pour donc
déjà une façon de résoudre le chômage
parce que le chômage c'est aussi des
emplois non c'est aussi beaucoup des
gens d'un non qualifiés via la culture
traditionnels comme ça a produit des
emplois qui sont à la fois agréable et
puis voilà mes voyages ferait du bien au
pays les cambodgiens effet salle et ça
aussi que les dix ans connaître les
villes à la vie à la campagne
voilà vous êtes une vraie soixante
huitarde je lisais l'autre jour dans
l'express
vos réponses au questionnaire de proust
alors vous demandez le bonheur parfait
quelle est votre définition du bonheur
parfait vous disiez faire ce que je veux
et si possible rien
quel est votre occupation préférée rien
[ __ ] je ne m'en lasse pas qu'est-ce
que vous avez le mieux réussi dans votre
vie anémone rigoler et rien [ __ ] c'est
cohérent avec ce que j'avais dit avant
vous dites c'est difficile de rien
[ __ ] dans une société qui valorise
tellement le travail et malgré ça malgré
votre désir de rien [ __ ] d'être monté
sur les planches
vous êtes jusqu'au 8 avril au théâtre
des variétés à 19 heures c'est
formidable ça s'appelle mademoiselle
werner de claude bourgeyx mise en scène
de jean louis saha
voilà ce que je pouvais si je pouvais
être contribué à le faire connaître
c'est vraiment de temps vous savez quand
on tient la plume convaincante dans mon
métier on en lit des taxes et des ont
fini par savoir un peu ce que c'est
qu'une bonne écriture et là vraiment bon
bah c'est une bonne écriture
le pitch est une vieille fille qui
fantasme alors elle est seule et elle
raconte sa vie et tout devient matière à
délire en fait elle raconte qu'elle va
l'hypermarché qu'elle se bat pour piquer
un chariot et ça devient une odyssée
quoi est ce qu'elle est tellement fermé
ne sont rien ou la fête c'est d'aller
l'hypermarché vous imaginez un peu voilà
la tragédie parce qu'il ya une tragédie
france à mes comics évidemment parce que
c'est trop de trucs super marché c'est
bonheur quoi
il ya un truc aussi sur la progéniture
on découvre que leur mlv un petit singe
comme un enfant comme elle n'a pas eu
d'enfant parce que cet office est
tellement frustré qu'à mon avis elle a
jamais baisé un moment de nous
le dit et tout ça ça se déchireront
soupçonne que les vierges à cet âge
avancé quand même
et alors bon bah et la frustration de
maternité tout à coup il délire sur un
petit singe qu'elle adopterait à la
place une enfant tout ça alors ça
commence drôle c'est fini à 30
exactement
alors il ya quand elle va à l'église
aussi c'est pour piller des troncs un
oui oui elles piquent les bielles
veulent l'être on est enfin là elle est
là tout une méthode pour impliquer un
maximum
enfin c'est très drôle j'y suis allé
chez le sait très bien ce théâtre des
variétés à 19 heures tous les soirs
c'est ce sapin chez les enflures parce
que ils ont acheté les affiches de
devant alors le théâtre très gentil me
dis bah on va faire les autres vitrines
en dessous pour faire de fiche un peu
plus petit qu'on voit c'est les gens qui
arrivent au théâtre met un on s'est
trompé de théâtre parce que deux
affiches c'est la ps2 ruquier bon les
mecs étaient offerts oui voilà que
j'adore mais enfin bref on aimerait bien
savoir ici que les affiches reçues
clément il pointe un problème
ben non seulement de toi car
dragonball absente labrador qui m'a dit
que mon coeur quoi bien des cartes alors
higuain out here une carte au hasard a
dirigé par la brise parce que j'ai un
copain voyant l'accueil qui sont venues
avec moi
il fut la prise elle est prise on peut
le 10 du mois guide moi non voici enfin
alors attention brice qui scelle voilà
alors tu m'as dit brice quatre premières
compagnies vous devez me faire dit pont
[ __ ] des pompes bon moment
[Applaudissements]
alors un bémol vous êtes venus comment
ici hello transport à benoît taxis
passent commande transporte comme ça
mais elle attend dé moi je serais vous
savez moi moi quand c'est moi c'est le
bus c'est le bus et le métro quand ya
pas vraiment pas de bus où les pieds
bien souvent ce serait le vélo si on
avait des endroits pour circuler sans
les guette autorails gueule mais bon
hélas pour venir la plaine-saint-denis
s'cusez moi bien c'est pas en réaliser
donc c'est non pas de touriste et le
font pas du covoiturage de vedettes tu
te ferais signer l'arrière on peut
s'organiser
je suis d'accord avec toi à mes modes
pour protéger la couche d'ozone vous
faites quoi
mais non mais la couche d'ozone c'est un
peu compliqué ça dépend pas de moi
les flatulences quand même que c'est non
c'est très peu et les brevets détenus
par des bovins des bovins ses 4 % et en
réalité les flèches sur le flat earth
des bovins en batterie parce que les
bovins qui broutent la prairie tout ça
et flac tulle normale et occupé par non
alors on continue
est ce que vous vous interdisez les
bains anémone non parce que je ne me
lave pas très souvent
et que donc je fume que cos et le jour
eh ben j'ai droit bas mais quand l'eau
de pluie je vous fais les endroits qui
pue réponse quand quand vous prenez
travail est il s'appelle quand vous
prenez une douche
est ce que pendant que vous vous
savonnez vous couper l'eau y'a pas de
savon c'est pas grave je croise tout
s'apprend pas beaucoup d'eau a sauvé
l'essentiel de l'eau c'est l'agriculture
monoculture alam al alhane oua j'allais
écrire des mots pour le à la noix il
faut arrêter le maïs mais pas encore de
nom mais je veux dire il faut faire du
goutte à goutte et fois c'est sûr les
biosciences pour les vieux pour y
arriver il faut surtout mettre des
cultures adaptées au climat au manque
d'eau qui arrive maintenant bon il ya
des stratégies qu'on puisse gérer
capitaux non mais pour de vrai capital
heures en parler de la bombe iranienne
un truc c'est vrai qu'il ya aussi plus
d'eau qu'on lui bon choisir votre fin du
monde
ben je suis tombé on hésite à des
plantes kiss kiss et qui se comporte
bien avec ça il ya bon moi j'ai un frère
qu'est l'agriculture et je peux vous
dire que les solutions existent
ouais c'est les politiques qui ne
veulent pas bouger dans la terre bien
surtout lui ce sont les bottes surtout
les suis parisien je suis pas
agriculteur surtout lui est ce que l'on
peut vous faire un dossier
oui mais je veux dire servir à résoudre
mon problème
penser à mes mollets à paris oui
qu'est-ce qu'on devrait planter au sol
et toi vous l'aviez vu j'ai vu
d'ailleurs un mur planté c'était en
allant vers l'allemagne ont vent venant
des invalides
alors tout à mur plainte et c'est
magnifique c'est c'est patrick delanoë
salah végétal it et verticale à ses
manies ses bons mais j'étais magnifique
ya un mec qui est spécial de seysses et
patrick lange c'est absolument sans
patrick blanc lui enlever dans le monde
entier
comment vous débarrassez vous des piles
usagées
moi j'ai pas de pile
ah bon pas de télécommande et votre
énergie c'est juste que c'est dû à quoi
ça coûte et jura sud d'où la douche
quand vous voyez une araignée voulaient
creuser
non avant alors j'ai scellé lors de la
soirée à fout dehors au ballet quand il
y en a trois mais il faut toujours qu'on
a régné à la maison quand on habite à la
campagne une petite toile dans aqua
pourquoi parce qu'elle vous fait les
insectes un essai la meilleure amie de
la maîtresse de maison là ça évite les
bombes aérosol qui aimeraient voir si
vous prenez les gens sont fiers
lellouche sur la renier je suis innocent
des vrais goûts et mes fans
ah ça c'est important est-ce que vous
portez deux jours de suite la même
culotte pour économiser de la vessie le
mois de suite ça c'est absolument intime
et privée je m'excuse je ne m'exprime
pas là dessus maintenant vous dépenser
beaucoup de lessive si vous l'avez votre
culotte frime pas là dessus sur ces
questions je m'explique je ne porte pas
de culotte on ne vous ne saurez rien
mais enfin vous ne saurez rien sur mes
culottes papa ce soir quoi jamais non
mais qu'il est cet autre moi et moi un
et les chaussettes pardon vous l'avez
tous les combien pareil pareil et bien
excuser un manteau de fourrure chez vous
oui a alors j'ai un vieux visons alors
que j'ai acheté à drouot et ouais ça
mille francs pas cher pour vision dior
c'est très bien très long prenez piété
d'origine en plus qui vieillit et que
donc je vais faire comme tous les
artistes au crac fauchés ou mais c'est
beaucoup plus chic en un peu lisse c'est
beaucoup plus chic en police donc ça y
est j'ai enfin trouvé le tous deux leur
comédie très vieux qu'elle commence à
user de sa l'an prochain ça va être un
petit imperméable an là dessus très chic
et tout ça on peut lire ici on est en
caisse les rues un régime
est ce que vous vous interdisez de vous
maquiller beaucoup pour sauver des
baleines toute façon j'ai horreur de
maquiller donc au maquis de force
ouais vous fabriquez vos vêtements vous
même
alors j'y viens non pas moi même parce
que quand même il ya des couturières qui
savent faire ça très bien
mais comme il ya beaucoup maintenant de
petites mains parce que faut voir que
cet ignoble galliano qui nous pugnac les
coutures parce qu'elle a viré les bonne
couturière qui savait faire des coutures
doigt dans des tissus des difficiles et
comme un espèce de chose là comme ça
plus fous des grandes chambres c'est
ignoble et donc moi je suis en train de
suivre la piste de ces bonnes premières
mains de haute couture des vrais
couturière et que là c'est vrai que
maintenant je suis parti pour ne faire
fabriquer mes vêtements par ces
femmes-là bon quand elle soit la
retraite aux blacks et tout ça
les enfants c'est pour les oui mais oui
mais oui mais ça vous pourrez pas le
trac est et ouest un flic moi j'ai
j'espère bien et parce que il faut
reconnaître que la mondialisation c'est
plus que de la merde la maintenance et
prix cassés c'est prêt alors il en coûte
aux y aller enfin c'est de la merde
c'est de la merde il y en a marre pour
les peaux et comme je suis à un âge où
les vêtements en dur parce qu'on sait ce
qui vous va que bon ben je dis pas l'âge
de ma fille vont elle va chez la petite
mère de james avait duré un an ça va
être pour la poubelle c'est la
croissance et la poubelle un truc
d'accord mais non moi oui en effet je
pars vers l'artisanat ou bien maintenant
dernière question va savoir si vous êtes
vraiment écolo ce qu'il y à des panneaux
solaires sur le vibromasseur
[Musique]